Has Battinson been outfitted?
Rumor-mongering website We Got This Covered
- a website, mind you, whose "intel" should
be taken with a grain of salt - is reporting
that sources have gotten a peek at the duds
Robert Pattinson will wear in the upcoming
The Batman - and if their report is accurate,
it'll be a version of the Batsuit quite unlike
any we've seen onscreen before.
"Why is he wearing his costume from the movie
he did 24 years ago?"
"If he wore the outfit from Clean and Sober,
you wouldn't recognize him."
"I'm the Batman!"
No, no, not that one…
This latest report falls in line with other,
independently reported rumors that The Batman
will be based, at least loosely, on the Jeph
Loeb-penned limited series The Long Halloween.
Published between 1996 and 1997 and featuring
art by comics great Tim Sale, the series is
set in the early days of the Dark Knight's
crime-fighting career, and features Bats shaking
down Gotham's criminals while investigating
a series of brutal murders.
According to the report, Pattinson's Batsuit
will feature a look very similar to the one
Sale created for The Long Halloween.
We're talking a grey suit with traces of black,
with a large black Bat-emblem on the chest;
a big, billowy blue cape with a blue cowl,
and very long, pointy ears.
We can't say for sure whether this rumor is
accurate, but it does stand to reason that
the look for Pattinson's Batsuit would have
been completed recently.
Sure, he screen-tested in costume before landing
the role, but it's likely that the suit used
for his test was from a previous production,
which is par for the course for superhero
reboots.
The Batman will be going before the cameras
very soon, so it's likely that its iteration
of the Batsuit is at least close to being
finalized.
The Batman writer/director Matt Reeves has
gone on record stating that his film won't
be a straight adaptation of any one story
from the comics, but based on what he himself
has said about it, it certainly seems like
The Long Halloween will be a heavy influence.
Reeves has said that the flick will be a noir-ish,
gritty tale, and we know that it'll feature
a pretty extensive rogues' gallery of classic
Batman villains, with Zoë Kravitz playing
Catwoman, Paul Dano portraying the Riddler,
and Colin Farrell in talks to play the Penguin.
That checks two boxes right off the bat, and
earlier this year, the rumor mill churned
forth another nugget: that The Batman will
see the Caped Crusader investigating a series
of ghastly killings plaguing Gotham.
If this turns out to be accurate, and Reeves
continues to insist that his movie isn't an
adaptation of any existing Batman story, then
we're going to have to go ahead and state
that the director is full of it.
At any rate, it would be pretty cool to get
a more comics-accurate depiction of the Batsuit.
The Dark Knight's look in previous movies
has always been pretty cool, but let's face
it, no previous version has had much of a
resemblance to anything we've seen in the
comics' pages.
"Tear resistant?"
"This sucker will stop a knife."
"Bullet proof?"
"Anything but a straight shot."
"Why didn't they put it into production?"
"Bean counters didn't think a soldier's life
was worth 300 grand."
From Tim Burton's Batman to Christopher Nolan's
Dark Knight trilogy, movie Batman's costume
has always resembled tactical body armor modified
to look like a Batsuit more than anything
else.
Particularly due to the fact that The Batman
will be giving us an earlier, less experienced
version of the Caped Crusader, we'd really
like to see something more in line with the
classic, blue-and-grey color scheme that DC
fans love.
One could make the argument that such a getup
would be a touch too reminiscent of Adam West's
Batsuit from the campy '60s television series,
but we would counter that Hollywood costume
designers are paid gobs of money to make superheroes
look awesome onscreen, so we probably need
not worry too much about that.
We'll see how it all shakes out in a year
and a half or so when the flick comes flapping
into theaters on June 25, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.